the best programmers are up to 28 times
better than the worst programmers quote
from robert glass american software
engineer and writer
great programmers are very rare in fact
only one percent of developers in the
world don't just write solid code but
have important intangible traits that
set them apart from the crowd
today i will share with you seven
intangible traits of great developers
and would like you to comment below
which one is the most important
so
let's start with the first one positive
attitude having a positive attitude
means being optimistic about situations
interactions and yourself
people with positive attitude remain
hopeful and see the best even in
difficult situations
in contrast those with negative attitude
may be more pessimistic and disagreeable
and typically expect the worst outcome
in tough situations
let's say a product needs to be released
to the market a great programmer will
step up and get the product released
whenever possible because they care and
their positive attitude helps them focus
on solutions and meet all requirements
developers with positive attitude are
willing to go the distance to get the
job done and bring their best every day
they don't let their ego get in the way
of constructive criticism they care
about product's success
a positive attitude is one of the key
qualities of a great software developer
second trait of the great developers is
strong communication skills
communication occurs in many different
ways and contexts from writing and
speaking to body language we use various
skills to convey and obtain information
however demonstrating strong
communication skills is about being able
to convey information to others in a
simple and unambiguous way
great programmers with strong
communication skills are able to
listen carefully
ask the right questions
understand problems and concepts quickly
break them down into hypotheses
and propose solutions in a coherent
manner
strong communication skills directly
correlate with strong programming skills
next trait of great developers
is effective time and task management
time management is the strategy of
planning out your available time and
controlling the amount of time you spend
on specific tasks in order to work more
efficiently
when you effectively manage your time
and tasks you will improve your
performance produce better work deliver
work on time
reduce your stress boost your confidence
become more efficient
take on new opportunities and grow in a
sustainable manner
effective time management comes easier
some people than to others but everyone
can develop habits to become more
effective
those who are considered as great
developers have developed excellent time
and task management skills
next trait of great developers
is quick learning ability
the best skill anyone can have working
in a rapidly changing industry is quick
learning ability
a quick learner is someone who is
capable of understanding new information
at rapid pace
it also goes beyond just comprehension
you need to be able to show that you can
apply what you learn to your work
great programmers are usually amazing
self-learners
they know how to stay updated and
relevant they have the ability to teach
themselves new languages and
technologies quickly
and often do so out of personal interest
outside of work they have the ability to
process information and make connections
on the fly every programmer will
experience a situation where they don't
know the answer but great programmers
will find different resources
talk to the right people and find a
solution no matter what
next trait is deep and broad technical
experience
every software engineer has a skill set
made up of different skills they've
acquired a skill set is deep and narrow
if you've mastered one to two skills and
little else and it's broad and shallow
if you can do a little bit of everything
without being an expert in any field
great developers have mastered both deep
and broad skills
working with different technologies long
enough they became experts and are
competent with many other technologies
therefore great developers with deep and
broad technical experience are able to
arrive at optimal solutions quickly by
combining their cognitive abilities and
diverse industry experience
they follow coding standards and write
code that is understandable and
commented so that it can easily be
passed on to someone else
an experienced developer is well versed
in best practices like agile development
and task management software they also
have mastered version control different
development environments and the process
of deploying applications
on the projects that require unrelated
skill set combined in unpredictable ways
broadly skilled engineer with a deep
skill set will contribute usefully to
most of them and will match precise
requirements
a great team player is another quality
of premium developers
sports teams are perfect examples of how
many players working together can
achieve much more than one player who is
acting alone
teams are created for several reasons
they may need to deliver a one-time
project or work together on an ongoing
basis either way teamworking is such a
vital way of completing projects
successful teams require people with
different strengths to work together in
a new effective way and at greater speed
to achieve top-notch results
a great team player is someone who
understands his role in the team uses
his strengths demonstrates reliability
communicates constructively
listens actively
embraces collaboration committed to his
team flexible and treats others in a
respectful and supportive manner
great team players always work on
developing and refining the skills that
will help them to make a valuable
contribution to the team they are in
and the seventh trait of great
developers is big picture focus big
picture focus requires big picture
thinking the ability to grasp abstract
concepts ideas and possibilities
imagine driving on the london bridge you
look at the left and the right only
while driving
well hopefully not you trained yourself
to cover both your left and right sides
as well as look back and far ahead in
front of you
if you only focused on a tiny word on
the bumper sticker of the vehicle
directly in front of you
you risk getting into a pretty bad
accident
that's essentially what big picture
thinking is looking at the entirety of a
plan or situation
in contrast a detailed oriented person
delves into the specifics of a project
or process in doing so they may lose
sight of the plan or the big picture
but this doesn't mean that one thinking
modality is right and another is wrong
instead they are both necessary to
function effectively and great
programmers master them both
in truth there's no way to say for sure
how well you might do as a programmer
until you try it still it's not a
coincidence that the best programmers
all share the traits above
with them it's just easier to succeed in
a challenging field like programming and
without them you'd be likely to struggle
it's important to understand that coding
is the initial door to success for
programmers but the desire to learn
should extend well beyond programming
knowledge because there is much more to
what makes a great programmer if you
found this video useful please like and
share it also make sure to subscribe to
the coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
have a wonderful day